[Music]
do you have anything pans
never bees will be fine Thank You G
alright here's a deal tubby
you're gonna Charma and I'm gonna poke
her with this thing and extract the
reality stone and get gone lickety-split
I'll be right back okay this the wine
cellar is just down here my father used
a huge barrel dokoni nail I see the
celery has a couple of games Hey Oh
clear which way oh you say something I
said I want to claw my eyes out but
unfortunately you weren't doing it good
cuz I already saw the awfulness will you
focus on focus this pretty place is
about to get are gonna fight real quick
by a bunch of freaking elves do you know
and I saw all these people who died so
this is a little bit difficult for me
okay so why don't you reach down deep
inside and try and find a small humanity
just tomato thing give me the thing you
think you're embarrassing all right
which way you don't know you used to
freaking live here for 1500 years not
forever I think maybe we are dead we are
so so dead
all right huh break is she's alone this
is a shot door some tragic things have
happened and he's decided you know what
I'm just gonna check out and eat pizza
and drink beer and that's what he's done
you know you're all right yeah that's
fine why you look like melted ice cream
everybody is Charlie we have a whole
bunch of Thor deleted scenes to break
down and a special Scarlet Witch scene
that we've learned about there was a
version of this where she actually goes
on the teams during the time heists this
sort of sets up what's going on during
Doctor Strange into the multiverse of
madness movie where she's gonna be
crossing over teaming up with him so
we'll break it all down we're doing that
Avengers end game blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best Doctor
Strange sequel theory on the video so we
start with Thor and rocket in Asgard
Thor is just so messed up that he can't
remember where they put Jane Foster when
they brought her to Asgard during Thor
the dark world the scene is called you
used to freakin live here
Thor reminds us that he's still a spring
chicken he's only about 1500 years old
as Guardians on average live about 5,000
years without any special extra help
it's implied because of the odinforce
that Odin is just a little bit older but
they played a little fast and loose with
those rules but rocket just cannot stand
Thor the whole time that they're there I
also saw questions after the movie about
whether or not this version of Loki
who's sitting in his cell here notice
them and realize what was going on
because just like Frigga can see right
through what they're doing I was raised
by witches boy I know you're not my Thor
Loki too could probably see through what
they were doing
Loki sort of pauses while he's flipping
the cup as they walk by so it does seem
like he senses something weird is going
on and he's just kind of waiting to see
how it all plays out because this is all
happening moments before the Dark Elves
assault them and you see curse turn into
curse in the cell and he tells them
which way to go because of what they did
during the time heist in the original
Avengers movie and Loki stealing the
tesseract and getting away that Loki is
now a completely different Loki from
this Loki during Thor the dark world
remember changing the past does not
change the future
so this Loki is now completely
unaffected by what that
other version of Loki did and that other
version of Loki is the one that we're
gonna see during the Loki TV series and
possibly cameo during Thor for love and
thunder and even if this version of Loki
did notice and did do something remember
when Captain America brought the reality
stone back and brought Thor's hammer
back
he completely collapsed any changes to
that timeline so everything during the
events of Thor the dark world here in
Asgard would have continued on it
happened the way they happened during
that movie just imagine the scene of
Captain America approaching Natalie
Portman's Jane Foster
sorry ma'am this is only gonna take a
second they're just like jabbing the
device right into her and jumping back
into the quantum realm love the Thor's
carrying around a pocketful of candy it
looks like he has a Twix and maybe some
Oreos they're definitely not gonna share
that with rocket but he's also carrying
around cans of craft beer and
travel-size liquor bottles if you pause
the movie and you zoom in you can
actually see the logos on his beers it's
creature comforts craft beer from
Atlanta the reason that wound up in the
movie because anytime you see Thor
holding a can of beer it's from the
creature comforts brewery is because in
real life the Russos have shot so many
movies in Atlanta for so long they want
up being huge fans of that beer they
love to drink it so Thor needs to be
drinking a lot of beer during the movie
they just made the beer that he drinks
from that brewery but even funnier he's
drinking a different flavor of the beer
in each scene that he's drinking beer
like he has a different can here than he
has here when he's walking The Big
Lebowski Thor then another different
flavor when he's an ass cart here maybe
that was just one of the ways that they
were able to lure Thor out of his little
cave we have beer on the ship all kinds
of different flavors there was also a
different deleted scene of Thor having a
reunion with Jane Foster while they're
here in Asgard to steal the reality
stone it was meant to be another pep
talk moment but because the scene with
his mother works so well it just wound
up being redundant in all the footage of
Jane Foster that they wound up using
when rocket walks in they just casually
take the reality stone from her is
actually footage taken from a Thor the
dark world deleted scene with rocket
digitally added in after the fact they
didn't even need to have natalie portman
on set for this moment and all the
Marvel people knew that Taika Waititi
was pitching Thor for love and thunder
so they knew that Jane Foster would be a
big part of that weather
Natalie Portman had already signed out
for the movie so they just collectively
decided to save anymore Jane Foster
stuff for what they would do during the
events of that movie I've just did a
video about the plot that they explained
back at the Marvel phase for comic-con
panel so I'll link that video at the end
of this but in the way that thor
ragnarok was a version of Planet Hulk
mixed with a couple other classic Thor
stories Thor for love and thunder is
going to be a version of my teeth or the
newer Jason Aaron my teeth or run mixed
with a couple of their classic Thor
stories but because they shot infinity
war an Avengers end game at the same
time so I don't know if when they were
working on this scene they had already
finished signing the deal for Thor for
love and thunder for Natalie Portman to
come back and reprise her role as Jane
Foster
there was another alternate version of
all these scenes that they worked on
instead of rocket going to Asgard with
Thor originally the team was going to be
Iron Man and Thor and they were gonna
have this huge Heimdall action scene
when they arrived at the Bifrost it was
meant to be a big callback to Idris
Elba's character with him using his
vision ability to see them coming
thinking it an assault starting this
huge fight with Iron Man when that was
still in the movie rocket instead of
going to Thor the dark world with Thor
went to the events of the Doctor Strange
movie to get the time stone with get it
Scarlet Witch who had not been snapped
at the end of Avengers infinity war so
there's a whole other version of this
movie where Scarlet Witch is around for
all this stuff that's going on but they
go back to get the time stone during the
events of the Doctor Strange movie when
he's training in Kimora Taaj with the
ancient one but here's the weird thing
in that whole deleted subplot they
completely got rid of they had a rocket
and Scarlet Witch going on an interstate
road trip like literally driving a car
from the triskelion in Washington DC to
the sanctum in New York City then using
the doorway to Cumorah Taaj in the
sanctum to get to Doctor Strange in the
time stone really early on part of the
logic for keeping Scarlet Witch alive
for this part of the movie and having
her crossover with Doctor Strange was to
help set up the plot of The Scarlet
Witch Vision TV show one division that
we're gonna see during Marvel phase four
in Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness movie because Scarlet Witch is
teaming up with Doctor Strange during
that and learning more about her magic
so they just wanted to establish more of
a pre-existing relations
between those two characters like
audiences see them together and say oh
it was cool seeing those two magic based
characters together for a little while
now we get to see them team up for real
in this big sequel movie but halfway
through that explanation you probably
realized why they got rid of those
scenes in that whole subplot they
decided that won an interstate road trip
in the middle of a fast-paced time heist
movie just brought the story to a
grinding halt - we already had scenes in
New York City because of Iron Man and
Captain America's team going back to the
events of the original Avengers movie so
we just made more sense for them to go
to the sanctum during that time period
and three at the end of the day just
made more sense to snap Scarlet Witch
during Avengers infinity war and save
any Doctor Strange crossover for the
Wanda vision TV show in the Doctor
Strange sequel movie even the writers
made fun of themselves for that road
trip idea like what were we thinking
road trip in the middle of his giant
time heist movie this is crazy
but let me know in the comments what's
your favorite Avengers endgame deleted
scene so far but I'm working on a couple
more Avengers endgame bonus features I'm
also working on a spider-man 3 video in
spider-man far from home and deleted
scenes those will all post in the next
couple of days but while you wait for
that click here for my Thor for love and
thunder video and click here for the
teaser for Doctor Strange into the
multiverse of madness thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]